email marketing is the most effective
way to actually Reach people why do you
encourage people to build an email list
I got hacked in 2015 right the people
who are the most freaked out when they
reach out to me are the people who have
built an empire in Social and they are
devastated because they've got a
notification from let's say Instagram
violation of community guidelines
account is gone which means money is
gone sponsorship's gone like it's all
gone I had the two-factor authentication
and I still got hacked and then every
once in a while here from someone that
says but I've got my email list and so I
can rebuild it